talk to us about uh solana maybe you can
describe first what it is and then we
can go through the uh the investment you
guys made
yeah so solana's blockchain um founded
in early 2018
uh were the largest investors in it it
launched the blockchain launched in
march of last year um tokenism binance
in april of last year uh today i think
it's number six or number seven on the
coin market cap
um
we solana is um a smart contract
blockchain so it performs for our
contracts um it is uh pretty radically
different in the design than ethereum um
across a number of dimensions um how the
system routes data around how it
executes transactions the programming
languages
it's a very
different take on a blockchain than
ethereum or bitcoin uh where ethereum is
this kind of like bitcoin's cousin in a
lot of ways
um solana is just like a totally totally
different animal um and the salon team
from inception their number one priority
was always make the system go as fast as
possible
reduce the block times to be as quick as
you can um now given the speed of light
and the amount of time it takes to go
around the world you can get that down
to maybe 200 milliseconds if you're
lucky um today's salon is at about 400
milliseconds
uh and then
enable it to execute transactions as
fast as humanly possible um so leverage
you know parallel transaction processing
on modern gpus which have called four
thousand cores um to execute as many
transactions as quickly as possible
um and salon was designed from the
ground up to do that you know as
efficiently as it can um and today it's
uh you know there's a thriving ecosystem
building all kinds of stuff on solana
there's defy there's tons of social
tokens there's tons of nfts uh there's
two kinds of games there's just a whole
huge amount of stuff all happening on
solana
um
fees are super cheap fraction of the
pennies and transaction transactions
confirm within a second or two um it's a
really magical experience to use talk to
us about when you met the team and the
initial investment that you guys made
yeah i'm at anatolian raj with the two
primary co-founders in april of 2018 and
invested shortly thereafter
um
the original slide deck for solana was
uh the title slide if you look at it
actually said uh nasdaq for blockchain
um anatoly who's the founder founder and
ceo of solano labs um and kind of the
chief architect of the system
uh
his vision from day one was i want to
run a central limit order book on the
blockchain um he did not at the time i
think have a conceptualization of modern
defy and all the interesting things
happening there but he understood that
like this was gonna be useful for
finance things and he said okay you need
to have an order book to run an exchange
and he designed to build you know the
world's largest fastest decentralized
order book engine um and solana was that
um that was his vision from day one and
it was very fortunate the blockchain
launched it in march or april of last
year and uh sam from ftx
came along like a month or two later uh
was really excited about d5
and was like can't build on ethereum
never gonna do what i wanted to do sam
really really really wanted to build an
order book um and solana provided them
the foundation needed to build an order
book
and so that turned into serum and serum
is now probably the most widely used
piece of infrastructure for solana based
to defy applications
what was the initial investment that you
made because i think from what i
understand this is probably one of the
best venture investments in at least
recent history uh walk us through kind
of the dynamics of the investment and
how you think about uh it in hindsight
yeah so solana raised money in may or so
of that year they raised of 18 they
raised another round in maybe august or
september
um
then kind of we went into into winter or
the winter after the november crash in
18
we ended up buying out a lot of other
investors who got cold feet after that
crash they did one more private round in
june of 19
which we led we led all three of those
rounds
and then they did a coin list sale in
march of 20
right as the blockchain launched
and the token's been trading freely
since then um the token launched a call
at 40 or 50 cents the last private round
was at 22 cents if i recall correctly um
and i think today it's at 150 or 160. um
in terms of dynamics in the round i mean
at the time a lot of people didn't like
salons one was a very uh
i think not popular bet among the crypto
uh crowd uh because it didn't feel like
the other blockchains um it made a
different set of trade-offs um and you
know anatoly was very very focused on
speed and performance and much less
focus on like crypto cryptography and
academics and economics um and so it
felt very weird um i take to most crypto
crypto people um that's exactly what
kind of drew us drew us to what he was
doing was a the clarity of the vision he
said i want to build a central order on
a blockchain
um we didn't know if it was possible or
not i was actually kind of skeptical it
could get done but it got done
um and you know he had the exact right
background to build what he's built
what was the cheapest price you ever
bought the token at was it at that 20
cents or something lower than that
uh
there was the very first round was it
four cents
so what do you think about that is this
kind of the uh i think one of the big
thesis that you all have is like is
venture capital like returns with uh
kind of shorter time frames to liquidity
is this kind of a prime example of what
you think the opportunity is outside of
uh kind of bitcoin or like the blue chip
type uh assets in the space
yeah um
i mean so i don't think there's gonna be
another solana um
i'm not counting on it happening in my
career um i would love it it happens
again but i'm not expecting it to happen
uh
and uh it's just a very weird set of
kind of historical circumstances that
led uh
the market as a whole to to neglect this
asset for for such a long period of time
and only recently as the market kind of
come around to appreciating it for what
it is
um but i think salon today is is pretty
close to blue chip within crypto i mean
it's number six or number seven you know
on market cap so it's pretty high up
there
um
the opportunity from here is now what's
the upside is it at its peak and you
know the the primary way to think about
solana is relative to eth
um today the market cap of soul is 12 or
13
of ethereum's thereabouts
um
and uh
you know obviously the barriers will say
it should be one percent of the bulls
will say it should be equal to ethereum
i mean you have to render your own
judgment of how this thing is going to
stack up and ranked i would say six
months ago it was still extremely
non-consensus to acknowledge that
something was going to give ethereum a
run for its money
um
today i think uh there are uh i think a
lot of intellectual capital within
crypto believes solana is going to
co-exist with ethereum um will it
displace ethereum i don't know i i think
it's actually pretty improbable there's
so much inertia um around the ethereum
ecosystem i don't think that can be
displaced
but
uh
it's very clear that this thing is going
to co-exist solana today is growing at
an extremely rapid pace
um users being onboarded uh assets um
being issued stable coins going into it
uh all of these things look at the last
90 days it's just vertical line from
call it uh a billion in assets to like
10 billion
you on your initial investment are up 3
3750x
a give or take which is uh which is
pretty incredible i see your smile which
means that uh you've thought of that
before um talk to us about how you think
about price movements today so solana
ran all the way up to you know 200 210
dollars then it crashed down to 140 150
it's almost hilarious to call it crash
because it was at like two or three
bucks at the beginning of the year how
do you think about price volatility as
uh a new network like this ends up
getting repriced by the
market yeah so we are not a trading firm
and i i generally try and ignore prices
to the best of my ability um i i never
actually open coin gecko or coin market
cap um i see prices as well through
twitter but you know if it weren't for
that i wouldn't know what the prices are
um we don't kind of
make uh we're under judgment on short
term medium term price movements
our time horizon is measured in years
not not weeks or months
um
so the question we would ask ourselves
is you know is this network compounding
at a sufficiently fast rate and if you
really go dig into developer activity
user onboarding dollar flow in the
system um all of those things right now
are compounding at an astounding rate
and i don't think that's going to slow
down um in fact i can make pretty
arguments why it's going to accelerate
um
does that mean solana can't go down from
here no dude we can wake up tomorrow it
could be 50 bucks you know that that's
on the table like this is crypto you
know that just kind of happens
um
but uh i'm we're super bullish
uh and yeah we're we're riding this
thing out
what's up guys bang bang your boy pomp
thanks so much for watching the best
business show our goal is to make this
the largest most actionable business
show in the world and to do that we need
your help we've partnered with sofi as
our exclusive sponsor because they have
a piece of software that we think will
help you take the information that we
share on a daily basis and make it
actionable we want every single person
to pursue and achieve financial security
and financial freedom in order to do
that you gotta act and sofi allows you
to do it so you can go to sofi.com pomp
today you can open up an account and
when you open up an account you can
invest in all sorts of different types
of assets etfs individual stocks ipos
bitcoin cryptocurrencies they even have
an automated investing function if you
want to invest sofi can help you they've
got a couple of different offers that
you can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right so far doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer it from that place to sofi
they'll pay you up to five thousand
dollars for doing it why wouldn't you do
it it's up to five thousand dollars for
free head on over to sofi.com today to
get started and come back tomorrow and
watch more of the best business show
together we're gonna build the biggest
show in the world
[Music]